[Music]
[Music]
we think today shows a fast pace but
Jesus look at this I feel like I just
snorted cocaine laced X through my
corneas everyone else is getting epic
battle introductions and Jubilee is over
here running from a mob getting caught
in an alley believed to be a mutant who
looks at Sabretooth walking down their
Street and second guesses this he has
fangs and claws Martha
[Music]
holy for a second there I thought this
was about to be a musical also things
girls say during their first period
these sentinels will soon be attacked by
mutants but ignore their threat because
they are not an official target - why
would this robot stop to squish a dog
that is clearly no threat at all
wouldn't you be using the tracking
program right now I know the show takes
place in the 90s but they're fictional
robot characters don't use windows 95
all right kids officer trying not to his
pants would be excellent at TV since I
got someone to play with we're basically
in the mutants version of satanic panic
and no name blondie here is dripping
with lost rather than freaked out that a
man with black eyes and red pupils wants
to play games with her sure as I watch
The Sentinel umber his way through this
episode crashing through buildings to
find one mutant and showing no
flexibility when the moment calls for it
I wonder why this thing was set at all
wait why was the Sentinel sent at all
Sentinel send it all his name was Robert
Paulson Stables Robert Paulson because
kids really want their hero and woman
eyes and have a firm grasp of insurance
policies also this x-men shopping spree
to the mall on Sentinel attack day has
evolved to the next level of convenience
[Music]
look I know gambit is a fan favorite and
they've been trying to get a solo film
off the ground for what seems like 30
years now but I'm just gonna say it
gambit is one of the silliest x-men ever
created he throws playing cards cards
[Music]
energy blasts time yeah cuz this
Sentinel is programmed to snatch Jubilee
but also hate polls she's not really an
intruder because you brought her here
while she was unconscious if anything
she's a kidnap victim trying to escape
but whatever helps you sleep better at
night professor exaggerated gambit says
what just about every single viewer was
saying when they had to wait 11 minutes
to see the only x-men character they
knew don't worry
petite you just heard Wolverines pride
that's all yep sadly 63% of x-men
battles are started because Wolverine
got upset about being bested by a girl
Professor Xavier is our leader and he
has named us the x-men roll commercials
anybody notify the kid's parents just
now realizing that Will Arnett's Lego
Batman voice was simply a second-rate
Cal dot impersonation earlier the car
has had more realistic license plates so
I investigated the significance of these
numbers thinking there could be an
easter egg situation I found a butter
Renaissance sewing pattern number five
six five six which we might have may
have been in tights which reminded me
that I have a strange mole that probably
needs a second opinion which reminded me
how difficult it would be to get to the
doctor's right now which reminded me
that this world is insane which reminded
me that I want to distract myself with
something entertaining which reminded me
that I am NOT entertained by the show
these women perhaps this is the second
time security footage has been used from
bulk cameras as if there were 4k options
in 1992 if there were enough cameras to
capture these highly specific angles the
image would be so zoomed out and grainy
he wouldn't be able to tell a face from
an ass nobody expects a certain will be
hiding right next to a building this
tree does a great job if you don't
notice anything else what's the matter
teacher's pet got cold feet no man can't
you see that Cyclops the stomach has
been taken over by an octopus beat
trying to rip a hole through his abdomen
he has serious issues to deal with here
calm down you know Matt remember when I
was 13 had me a boyfriend music and
stories ex that skip hey whenever I got
into trouble at school I used to turn
myself into the principal man morph
seems like such a fun character to have
on this show glad we're gonna get to
witness many adventures with him
involved you're supposed to know
everything what makes us like we are
anyway you're telling me this
conversation hasn't been addressed in
however long they've been at the school
together and even if it hasn't then why
the would you ask it right in the middle
of a goddamn mission dududu damn I hate
it when I install an amazing infrared
laser security system and I forget about
all the pipes that are lining the
ceiling that some [ __ ] can use to
avoid them everyone comes to the x-men
for the promises of action-packed mutant
mayhem but they stay for the
philosophical discussions of our place
in the world I mean does everyone have
red hair just wish I knew what what's
happening in there if dad was me and dad
you wouldn't have to work yeah because
he'd have the guards all cut up in a
thought-provoking game of old maid
seriously gambit oh shut the [ __ ] up
Beast no you didn't remember no humans
are to be harmed except this guy storm
electrocuted him instead of letting
Wolverines slice him to pieces
Becca we're under attack the vocal
direction for this character was
apparently sound like you were choking
on a rutabaga in case she confused it
with Detroit Alabama I'm just gonna say
you can use too much highlighter
[Music]
whomever is teaching the heroic
one-liners class at Xavier school for
the gifted youngsters should be fired
okay but four seconds ago gambit killed
these guys so
don't get much better than this
she has a thin strip of fabric cutting
off circulation to her wah ba-bah Gaga
callaloo get ice
no one will be seated during the
emotional destruction of a co-worker's
vehicle we take you now to the emotional
flashback driving rocky for portion of
the x-men series also this is super
weird Wolverine is flashing back to what
happened after the episode already
showed them coming back from the battle
why does he know but why he seems to be
the only one who can destroy the
Sentinels everyone else is getting their
asses kicked and he's like zap-zap we
may not know why is laser eyes are
inconsistent and sometimes lob a limb
off another time barely penetrate the
armor but he is the most effective
weapon they have I don't think this is
how storm could carry someone through
the air Cyclops looks like a stiff board
rather than hanging on to her for dear
life she's barely touching his left
bicep for sake and he's just cruising
like flying is his superpower
yeah a lot of mutants elf narrate their
abilities while they're using them
that's perfectly normal but what isn't
normal is your hand suddenly changing
colors rogue should see a doctor right
away because her gang made her green and
now the President of the United States
and now someone got me a tub of bleach
or a blowtorch because these televisions
have been overtaken with black mold I'm
sure whatever she's saying cannot be as
important as identifying what the sort
of bird this is it's a turkey vulture
isn't it golden goddamn turkey vulture
yeah why don't you go back to the Freak
Show
and this random bar [ __ ] is Jack
Nicholson ting so hard I would give all
the sins back if he started talking
about how we need him on that wall done
nothing wrong you just want to help her
and you have he is not see they don't
have to be stealthy when they follow
their target because they're protected
by the love of children everywhere
except for more nobody loved Morphin he
died Oh Bob what was stopping her from
opening these on her own she can
short-circuit machines and when she was
found earlier were just fine so they can
kick the Sentinels asses with minimal
differences from the first fight we saw
this fight is much better and it
confirms my suspicions that they let
morph die because his laugh was just the
worst
you guys are the best foster parents I
ever had Wow to build up to well nothing
you will come to visit us won't you
does a mall baby chili fries could have
just said rarely I won't go so will I
just a possibility make sure you click
that Bell icon but clicking the little
bell icon is how you make sure you get
notified every time we release a video
so click beside scent of weed chili
he thinks he's caught me off guard oh my
god I've caught him off guard did you
find the child give me the child
Sarah beware I have been generous up
until now I want to ask you some
questions Jubilee have you ever walked
out of a mall into a huge parking area
and realized you'd forgotten where you
parked your car what do you want to be
when you grow up what's the right tip if
you call the plumber to your home lately
stop or I'll say stop again and you go
in pieces I will do all right I will
enter you